for tonight's theme I thought we would
talk about retreating because in chess a
lot of the times there's really strong
moves where you go backwards and I mean
it's so easy and chess to just think
forwards because it's picking is on that
side the fastest route is just to go
forward and so very often people miss
backwards moves or retreating moves and
for whatever reason with the human brain
there is something about night retreats
that are just particularly difficult so
we'll see at least some of these will be
some some night retreats
welcome back
okay well we'll go over to the board
I guess we'll stop painting by number
that's basically all we're gonna do I
mean all the classes don't get taped it
we just paint by number so that's I had
to get my practice doing that and I will
look right now at the game this was a
game that was played between Alexey
Shiraz and Vladimir Akopian that's a co
peon with a P not vara Cobian who'd be
lecturing here in an hour but this is
Shroff Akopian and it is white to move
in this position so the class has
already had a little bit of time to look
at it I'll give you guys another minute
or two and then we'll we'll discuss the
position so it is white to move and I
would ask you to assess the position is
white winning drawing losing what's what
is white really playing for here what's
the assessment and we'll come back and
then we'll talk about what White's plan
should be
yeah very well said white we don't know
if he's winning but he can at least hold
a draw you have something to say yeah so
white definitely has that's the big
thing so we got a three-on-two going on
over on the queenside here so that's a
big issue and the fact that we're up
upon is also a huge plus as white so
it's very definitely said I mean maybe
this is a win maybe it's a draw
but at the very least white should not
be losing in this position so whether he
can win with this advantage over here is
yet to be seen we can imagine sometimes
left ok the bishop can't get back as was
stated here to come get these pawns if
the King you know gets sort of delayed
he goes over here to protect the pawn or
something white will be able to crash
through and make a pawn either what's
move like c5 let's make it green I like
a green and if you take we can push and
we can end up and we can go make upon we
can also consider starting with a5
sometimes but we do have this
possibility of creating a passer it's
not quite gonna work out if the black
king is in time to you know run back
into this zone and stop the pawns but
that is a huge part of the position so
that's that's the first step
yeah king of two and that's exactly what
was played this does prevent black from
getting his Bishop into the game now
that Bishop is is really sealed out of
the game and that causes a big problem
for black and okay in the game he took
this pond which is not really the best
move I probably should have played King
F for just improved as his King he's
still close enough to go stop the pawns
can anybody tell me what's wrong with
this move came to d4 he's gonna lose his
pastor yeah how do you want to start we
want to start pushing these pawns c5
this just wins on the spot yeah okay I
mean yet cuz if you just take we just
push and the king is now not in time to
go back there and stop the pawns so this
would just win on the spot however this
would have been a far superior move and
it's still unclear that white can
actually win this position so this is
probably blacks best bet in this
position but okay he played here so if
this works if this forces a draw then
very good for black now again in my
preparation for these lectures I try to
gauge the level by showing these puzzles
to people in the 18 to 2,000 rated range
just to see how they do with the puzzles
and one person was unable to find the
answer here and the other person was
able to find it rather quickly so I
would I suppose it's not the easiest
move in the world because you notice
people higher rated than most of the
class here had some difficulty with it
yeah yes yeah King takes f3 excellent
okay excellent so you kind of spoiled
the answer here hopefully they didn't
hear it did they hear it good thing okay
so he did find the the move here so go
ahead and you might want to pause your
your videos at home and we'll go ahead
and give the answer out here
yeah the winning move as stated good job
Owen king g2 a retreating move that
perhaps black missed because okay you're
hanging in your night I do want to show
first the problems that you might
experience with either night retreat
these both seem very tempting okay it
doesn't doesn't matter they're exactly
the same night to f2 let's just say for
example well now I play king d4 this
isn't very easy for white no way it
actually has to try to play for the draw
here you know you have to be the one
that's trying to go for the draw because
black just simply goes and he takes all
of your pawns and alright if you ask
your computer they'll be like yeah this
is some draw the knight is in time he
takes your pawns you're in time to go up
there and you know get your your knight
into a close enough location that you
can force the draw because the black
king has to waste so much time and okay
white is just in time to go back and get
there but this obviously isn't what
White was playing for he had this
monster advantage so that retreat would
not be correct but perhaps just this
king retreat in this position was missed
by mister Akopian and this just just
wins cleanly so maybe he just missed it
because okay obviously we can take this
but now the winning move is what c5 and
okay we can look at taking it in the
game he didn't take which makes it sort
of easy you just take this and okay
here black resigned the white king just
forces his way in forced as the king out
of the way and the pawn promotes it is
it's a slight in interest to uh to take
care I think the next move is kind of
easy a five I'll go here just because
this is v6 I'll take it you want to take
it much better so taking it here is
wrong you go that's let's let's go all
the way down the board and everybody
Queens so this should be a draw because
okay we can take this pawn with either
piece but yeah so the winning move was
of course promoting with check so you
don't need to take it you can just go
promote with check and this should be a
win for white okay so that was the first
example of a nice retreat that perhaps
was just overlooked even by a very
strong player and 2605 at the time of
this game and he must have thought all
right they go here and then the knight
has to retreat and I get to go collect
his pawns but it wasn't that clear the
King retreat was what the opponent
missed all right very good we'll move on
this will be our second game after the
motorcycle gang goes by we'll get this
but with your mic maybe they could hear
that motorcycle gang they can hear
anything
oh yeah jacket up so this is the game
between david navara and Anish gary from
the european team championship 2013 very
good players will be looking at it from
Gary's perspective he had the black
pieces here it was a draw
what what's really funny too as I've
showed this to three or four people that
was everybody's immediate thing oh it's
a draw
okay obviously people like to joke that
in each draws a lot based on some of his
most recent performances but he's very
strong player and he did win this game
so it's he doesn't always just draw
okay so white played rook c1 attacking
the bishop we'll just show a couple
moves so we can get the feel for the
game there should be for a move which
might not have been obvious to people
because I mean sure it doesn't look like
good trade for me you know a knight for
a bishop but with the rook coming in and
aiming at two targets
this would help black win upon so he's
not really still very interested in
taking the bishop also he's not
interested in blundering his rook
so you're an interesting move
interesting decision by white not not
bad at all
h4 so he's preventing ideas like g5 g
for undermining the protection of a 5
and my question for you guys and we'll
take a minute here or so ken black take
on b2 that's I mean I guess that's one
of the questions I mean white did not do
anything about the pawn that was
attacked
so should you take on b2 or is there a
better move I'll give you guys a minute
here and you can pause your video at
home for additional time
right so here yeah here's exactly the
idea if you take on b2 this is there's a
wise idea
rook b1 and fish up anywhere and the
rooks gonna take on b7 that's that's the
idea
so should you still should you still
take on b2 or do you guys have another
move that you want to suggest okay okay
interesting
9e 7 to d5 this is your idea right so
much the sevens bad you say so so this
isn't so bad I mean I can probably just
not lose my pawn
you have a dark squared bishop I can go
on a light square you want to take my
pawn still I don't know what I would do
but okay let's just give you the let's
just give this to you for a second you
want to go here I take you yeah I'm
attacking your bishop
you take what my shop
you're gonna take this fun and now
everybody's like super confused Knight
c3 what is that what does that do okay
then you do you think I'm gonna I don't
know my my winning I have a lot more
pawns and I'm taking all your problems
so it's funny XO I can't move my pieces
but you have to use both of your pieces
and at some point I'm gonna kick this
guy away and then so yeah I think I
think I defended properly there so
that's actually it's an interesting idea
I didn't I didn't have this idea I don't
think it's quite the strongest move it
wasn't played in the game in the game
and I tried to trick you guys a little
bit
so Mario walking in the door you might
know the answer just because he I didn't
trick you I didn't use verbal trickery
do you know what black should play here
say Bishop takes b2 and then hope the
editor doesn't cut this out oh good move
good job
Mario Roper will say okay this was
played in the game so obviously he sees
White's a little trick but he allows it
so what's the point
rook b1 Bishop went back and again if
you take the bishop my rook comes up to
d4 and at least wins upon so he took in
and his chest so that's why I like to
trick you guys so chess works okay so
what was black spinel this traps the
rook and takes it okay how are you gonna
do it this should be 6x one that was
played and okay so it seems kind of
unfortunate here there's actually a
couple different ways that we can escape
the danger here okay in the game he
tried ecigs strung sacrifice just
opening up his pieces I don't have what
do you took I mean why not take the pawn
excellent and here a mistake this is
actually fine for white his rook is not
quite getting trapped but after this
move it appears that the player with
white has missed something so we'll see
if the audience can see what a very
strong player did not see in the game
yet a certain blind spot
okay how do you open the exchange 95
which does appear very good I suppose
all and yeah if you're looking at all
the safe squares that my rook has this
is how we can start to think that maybe
it will be trapped I only have one so
I'll go there and King f8 I take this so
this you know thank you okay so it's not
quite right but that's obviously sort of
feels like it'll be a part of the
solution how do we how do we trap the
rook all right let's give a little give
a genesis move a try here King f8 and it
seems pretty decent and now you are
ready for with this idea of trapping the
rook so I will take this now if you move
here you're a pawn is and defended so I
should at least take that I'll stick
your knife or take a rope I'm to give it
probably take the knight and I could
take anything I want though yeah do you
want check excellent hey only realistic
laws would say 98 an excellent
retreating move and undie eight not only
do we attack the rook but we attack the
we protect to the pond so even when you
go to the only square now King f8 just
works and the rook would be trapped
which I believe is us on the game he
just gave up in exchange this way and up
the extra material he was able to
convert this as black here also this
also was funny somebody couldn't figure
out this movie there what if I play
okay ah joke's on you I'm out there
sacrum that was how come no so easy for
you guys just just because it's easy
okay okay so that was just a very good
example and it it would appear
what kind of made this work to is well
now that this diagonal is wide open they
gave us the additional trick that we
needed which was to make sure unrep ba
that we had this check going on All
Right see you Owen and again it's these
sort of night moves these backwards
night moves are really difficult for a
lot of people and okay even you know
extraordinarily good players have missed
you know some of these backward moves in
their their careers here we'll go to the
last example for the night this is the
game between aron nimzowitsch and Akiba
Rubinstein it was played in 1926 these
players have played each other quite a
lot some of the best players up there
time so it's a very interesting position
it will go a few moves I like to give
you guys just a little bit of the plot
and alright in this position white took
a little bit more space makes a lot of
sense
castles Queen f3 so white is playing on
the Kings side he's gained a lot of
space over there very good develops his
last piece you know f5 sort of
challenging the amount of space in the
White has alright came over to e1 and
after the exchange here well pause for a
minute and again I would kind of like
for the audience once more to kind of
give me the the assessment so before we
start looking for the move let's spend a
couple minutes just trying to assess
who's better or you know which pieces
are good or bad you know who's got the
better pawn structure say for King any
any sort of normal tools that you would
use to assess the position if you can
identify any aspects of the position it
might be really helpful going
forward so uh so we're first I want to
hear the assessment and then we'll try
to come up with a plan here for white
okay very very well said yeah I mean
it's a white does have the open file
good bishop the Queen also is I mean
it's very good she might be able to come
in here sometimes that's a great piece
this rook has a future
this Knight is okay it's not the
greatest but he is at least keeping some
control over be for which you know could
be important so that's that's okay and
yeah black does have his chances to if
you can ever sink a knight into one of
these squares then perhaps you will will
be doing very good
so I mean yes so white is a little bit
better here I would say let's so this
one is going to be sort of a strategical
puzzle which is good because I guess
this class is strategy session so
occasionally I'll teach strategy in this
class but okay but we'll see if anyone
come up with a plan for why I don't want
to give away too much just yet oh I'll
give you guys a chance in that home
positive video I suppose to it's it's
worth asking you know in a position like
this when you're you're just seeing it
now for the first time how do you make a
plan I mean what really what really is
going on in your mind how do you
actually come to a conclusion for what
what sort of plan you should take I mean
are you're just looking for just a right
move or are you thinking somehow about
the position in a different way and I
said so one of the the most basic
elements in planning and just chess
strategy in general is when you see a
position like this or any position
really and black doesn't have any
immediate threats if black had some
immediate tactical threat or you know we
had to worry about our safety of our
King or something
the situation might be different we need
to you know very accurately concretely
calculate his threats and defend against
them or if we're checkmating them we
just need to calculate all the weights
I'll check me but as it is black doesn't
really have any threats in this position
sort of a stagnant position centers is
relatively closed here there's one open
file that's being used for the rooks
right now see file also could be used in
the future but due to the closed nature
really there's there's a lot of time for
maneuvering so we want to kind of figure
out so if we're white
what is our worst place piece so just if
you can think about that for a minute
and then just imagine you can pick it up
you can put it anywhere you want you can
teleport however you want to think about
it what would the dream Square be for
your worst place piece and in general
this is one of the best ways to go about
finding a plan in any position just take
a piece that's on a bad square find the
best square for it and put it there
which you know it's sort of
oversimplified but it's actually can can
really help you out a lot if you're
having difficulty coming up with plans
yeah round up the deep on okay you want
to attack this okay so you want to bring
the bishop over here okay yeah he's he's
not the best I mean he has some purpose
here but let's go ahead and run with
this this idea for a minute okay I'll
just complete my development just to see
and you want to play Bishop F - yeah so
unfortunately I feel like this might be
an issue so let's just I guess
tactically doesn't work you you
undefended this guy it's an interesting
idea though I mean okay yeah this is
this sort of an awkward piece this night
on g3 he's he's definitely not the hero
of this particular position here he
sorta offside he it's not really where's
he going
I mean he's wears he wasn't really gone
now yes so that sort of looking for the
answer to the teleport question if we
can pick this up let's just pick up our
night let's put it wherever we want
where would we put it if we could if we
can cheat a little bit
f7 check losing here yeah be 5 d5
central squares are pretty good we do
want a nice safe permanent home b6 I
mean okay so even if you can do that you
forward to me but I mean I have to give
my bishop so I mean okay that's I mean
that is sort of one of the good square
that we might want to go to and you know
the chip position might change a little
bit and that might be a good square g4
is a [ __ ] g4 is a horrible square but
you made you an g5 yeah that's that's a
great outpost for a knight and you'll
notice even if we give it this position
I mean look how great our bishop is
cutting you off let's just let's just
put this guy here for a second even if
you play h6 yeah the Queen comes in and
it pins so you can't even take the
knight so yeah these these squares that
we identified these are definitely part
of the solution here
those are good squares for the knight to
get there exactly so the question is how
do we figure it out what's the move
order how do we get our Knight to one of
those squares exchange bishops which one
and now what okay Bishop e6 so I mean I
would assume this was a very nice piece
why did you want to give this guy away
you want put pressure on the e-file and
I mean I do have a retreat it'll be
funny okay good if I just play a move
like this
I get my way now this blenders I've
wondered um yeah I'll retreat that's
funny
it's the theme of the lecture so I'll
retreat because it's funnier I don't
know I mean I I really liked this Bishop
I don't feel if even if I don't play
that I place just any random move or
whatever I don't I don't feel like that
was a very good trade for you that's
white because this Bishop is awesome you
know he's gotten off the King that's
gonna be very useful in a lot of lines
so yeah you know and that's also worth
considering which pieces do you want to
train and which ones do not and I think
the first piece that people noticed was
a really good piece when we asked was
this Bishop it's your best piece so you
know I don't want to trade the best
piece off for a piece that hasn't even
moved yet and it's my best piece you
think we should buy Knight h1 really in
a retreat in class we're and we're doing
what's your path yeah Wow look at that
always play Knight h1 yes I that's a
Feingold favorite move and here it is
the correct answer
Knight h1 so look at that it's it I
think this might be in my system I think
it is I'm not sure it's not somewhere I
found it but I think it is in that book
mm-hmm and I mean why wouldn't it be
this is like his greatest maneuver ever
so okay black it's on develops his piece
yes improve your worst piece so yeah
don't trade your best pieces for their
pieces that aren't so great
put your bad pieces on better squares
and if you have bad pieces you can trade
for their good pieces like I think too
and even if we go back to this initial
position if if black just said let's
just take both of these guys off the
board that'd be good for black I mean
you got rid of one of your best pieces
so if we just means cheating we took
both the bishops off the white light
square bishop for white is a lot better
so I'd be just a good deal for white
okay f2 alright in black contest the
e-file
so white keeps control of it okay so
white still owns the file the trades
woman rook and now he goes here
why didn't why didn't he go here can
somebody tell me and the white isn't
black one it may be trade the rook you
know maybe he wants to trade some stuff
cuz he's got the worst position here
maybe he doesn't like White's pressure
so I mean this seems like a natural
enough move I mean please trade takes in
Queen d5 excellent yeah that's this is
really really powerful for for white
okay and you can play a move like this
but you're losing your partner so this
would be good for way also funnier I
don't know if it's better or not but
funnier is Queen d5 just with the idea
so again you can't even take my rook
because I this this checkmate well yes
that's the idea so that's that's good I
mean you know so he can't even really
challenge the file at least not yet
so he went to d8 retreating he's a pro
but the bishops gonna come to c6 so he's
probably thinking well this isn't such a
great piece he oh he's coming up with
the plan he's like well this looks like
a great diagonal for a bishop which it's
true so he goes back to d8
now 9 h3 we're getting closer to g5 no
bishop c6 exactly yeah that was wit
Queen h5 yes so it's becoming easy to
play yourself
it's g6 and only this is a sort of move
you want to see with white it's a bit
weakening
our dream would be one day on this
diagonal maybe something will happen if
this guy could disappear and our Bishop
could go to c3 or somehow get on that
diagonal well then we be living the
dream we'd be able to take advantage of
this weakness here yes oh yeah h6h for
whichever aah he went here for a
specific reason we'll understand on the
next turn here in g7
95 is very tempting and and it's it's
probably pretty good I assumed the
reason for blacks last move was to kind
of fight against this idea you can play
a move like h6 and you can go here and
you know okay but I didn't and you
really want to trade that night you know
it's not exactly what I wanted to do
also I mean I don't really want to go
back I mean I can I can retreat this but
I mean how's that really gonna work out
for me this isn't exactly what I dreamed
of when I was coming up with my my
impressive Knight maneuver so he has a
little bit of patience you know okay so
I understand I go here he plays h6 and
my my knight might come off the board so
he came up with an even stronger move
here so you do want to be paying
attention to your opponent's threats to
you know I mean 95 is the move you want
to look at it and then when you see h6
you want to maybe rethink the move here
so you miss struggling so this is this
is a very powerful move Bishop a5 see
there you got a little tactic here
rookie 7 okay and this is an idea that
will sort of be introduced into the
position in in a minute here but oh yeah
I'll take it
did you see this position when you went
for this I think this was sort of a
forced line mm-hmm yeah right so here
doesn't work because yeah so that's not
quite right but that is an element in
the position so going forward that
actually is sort of an idea that we're
going to see we we do see you know the
squares we want our pieces to go to for
the moment that's just not quite working
because I just take all your stuff and
so here's a really surprising move so if
you haven't found it at home go ahead
and pause your video if you want to want
to keep looking what the move Queen f2
is a very powerful retreat okay we're
prodding at the deep on but also we're
gonna force one of your pieces to go
passively defend upon which is very
important for us at this point and the
piece that preps makes the most sense is
the bishop so this is this is sort of a
very important position now so okay
we've been improving our our position
and now be four so we're again we're
trying to force you to an even worse
position go away on this diagonal don't
even think of ever coming back to this
this good diagonal just go away okay
good so weight is very slowly
methodically improved the position and
now he actually missed an instant win so
this is a split on the game somehow I'm
still showing you even though you know
his his chess artistry points went down
for this one
I did show Jason woolum games so I mean
the show has been to some pretty low
places actually what I liked about that
one too is he put it in the beginner
playlist that's great instead of like
the intermediate playlist yeah that was
great yeah yeah sounds great it Bensimon
got you good um sorry I mean does anyone
see the instant kill I think it's
something new we might be able to find
it's yeah it's tactical mm-hmm I mean
it's not it's not sacrificing anything
is just playing a powerful move it's
it's I guess it's time to go mm-hmm it's
an attacking move and he did sort of the
same idea but he allowed black to play a
slightly better defense
we need this is yes this was the game
right exactly threatening to put a real
con on e7 I'm still holding my queen but
rook to e7 so that was the game that was
the game excellent yeah that's the game
yeah you know yeah well I'm gonna tell
you nothing
well what's what did what a black play
in this position that's the question so
again we got to think about our
opponents plans you know our plans are
great but if we don't take into account
what blacks gonna play I mean what's
what's the point I was backing to defend
against the threat of this incursion
rookie a so this is the game
okay and bukka's defended somewhat white
is obviously better here and well we'll
come back because that was indeed the
game well yeah now we want to know what
the killer blow is
so make rookie 7 better we want to play
rookie 7 but we don't want him to do
that
see that's why we need the other
microphone because anyway here you can
make all sorts of random noises this one
doesn't pick it up it's good for you
this week but yeah yeah but I hope you
at home they want to hear all your
noises you know it makes them feel like
they're really in the room they don't
understand the don't we hear noises that
are being man yeah how about we nee one
even Jason well I'm thought about it but
didn't have the guts to never guts and
notice how that is prevented this
defense and this just is crushing you
can't play here because then I take
twice you you lose material and okay the
next move is here and resigns both
maneuver II stuff and they're both
maneuver II yeah and so yeah and again
it's he had the right idea he just I
don't know if he overlooked this defense
or he just didn't consider Queenie one
or underestimated that he probably wants
his queen done h4 but she can go there
in the future after going to he won she
can go back to h4 in certain lines so he
didn't miss you know the immediate
crushing win but okay this is very
pleasant for white I mean white is white
is doing very well
all rips attacked
so doesn't want to trade and he's saying
if you take care which big mistake
I think 95 you can do better there
should have fine we can do better
better than Bishop f5 the sounds not on
consignment you're so sad
Oh with what
yeah go with the Queen ah
and if here checkmate
if here this is the prettier way to get
yourself checkmated cuz I get to use my
bishop and I get to do the crisscross
applesauce so that's pretty exciting
um okay so I'm not taking your rook I'm
not taking your I'm not taking your work
all right
that's poison and yeah I do not want to
open up this diagonal definitely okay
native so you know I got to come towards
the come towards my King gonna have to
do some defense I attack your rook so
now what are you gonna do this is
interesting really it's getting concrete
now we're gonna make some concrete
threats here so they're going to come in
it's white to move so now this says
let's let's be concrete now we calculate
this is this is time to calculate now
because white now has a winning position
but how well can we calculate
yeah Bishop takes f7 yeah exactly which
is perfect okay strategically if we we
can't get ourselves out of strategy mode
it's like whoa okay great Bishop why
would you give up your great Bishop
we're talking about how great he is well
now we have a real concrete reason the
knight is going to g5 we're gonna have
lots of threats okay I mean so he takes
back and I mean now we just have some
real concrete threats here and did you
see the follow up 95 absolutely I mean
g8 what's your worst place peace here if
your wife the Queen she's what do you
mean she's in Queens good night Knight
fantastic look very good the bishop the
lonely lonely bishop we can't decide
what color he should be in March so
what's our worst place peace I mean it's
the bishop yeah I mean with we've
discovered this and so again let's let's
try to figure out where do we want it
where could we put that Bishop c3 would
be good if there's not a pawn here
yeah it's obviously fantastic diagonal
and that is part of the answer so you
want to be too and then you know you
know you're not really making a threat
by doing this mm-hmm all right I'll tell
you this snow I'll give you this move
okay you traded the ropes okay I'll give
you this one
you want to play night takes is that
that's your move okay I will take 27 I'd
defend something very tricky okay he
starts with another improving move the
bishop is gonna come into play but let's
make one more strong move first
let's bring activate the queen it's come
a different way I should went to c6 and
now where's the check and then I think
you you've hit on the idea b5 a
fantastic move and I mean look at this
route access route we've given to our
Bishop so in the game he didn't take
this if you take tit Abby however you
want to take this this is just too too
dangerous
we're coming in we're going like this I
might also want to preface this with a
move like this just to prevent you know
any defense that you might have and all
right how are you how are you I can end
up stopping this it's just gonna be kind
of painful for you
so yeah b5 and is his opponent just
decide okay Queen g7 forgoing the piece
and okay I mean a piece up the game is
over so he simply trained it and took
the piece and up a piece he had no
problems converting this and he went on
to win so again just to go back to the
critical position which is before all of
this this was again sort of a more
strategical solution to the puzzle so we
found our worst place piece we found the
best square forum we rerouted and
we were at some points we were willing
to get tactical once we figured out real
concrete solutions to the problems and I
was a very nice end to a very very
strategical and well played game so I
hope that gives you some ideas about
retreating and helps you overlook some
of your blind spots that sometimes
people have they have a hard time
looking backwards so yeah if you liked
it go ahead and hit a bike share
subscribe tell all your friends and see
you guys next week
you